hello okay uh I guess people have
stopped trickling in so let's get
started uh before our keynote I have two
announcements to make uh number one uh
we all encourage you to stay for the
happy hour five to seven uh in this same
venue and then uh I mean the networking
social hour and the number two
um uh we the shirts have arrived so if
you haven't picked up your shirt yet uh
you can pick it up sometime throughout
the day they're at the front and with
that uh we can start the keynote it's my
pleasure to introduce Holden carao
Holden is uh her pronouns are uh she and
her she's a transcanadian and she has a
lot of experience with distributed
computing she is a spark open source
contributor and part of the spark
maintainer committee she currently works
at Netflix previously worked at Amazon
Apple and Google on distributed
computing as well and I personally want
to let you all know that Holden has an
entertaining twitch stream as well that
I tune into sometimes and you should all
check it out and that join me in
welcoming Holden
[Applause]
cool awesome thank you thank you so much
for having me I'm I'm really excited to
be here
um in part because I'm excited for what
I'm talking about today but also I just
really love the python data Community
um so y'all are awesome and I think
that's something that we sometimes
Overlook is how important communities
are and I think you know no Community is
perfect but I'm really really happy to
be a part of the Python data Community
y'all are rad
um and yeah if you want to like follow
me on social media or watch these twitch
live streams where I get confused doing
things that I've done several hundred
times uh swear at my computer pick up my
dog
um sometimes get distracted but mostly
mostly stay on topic you can come and
join me there I do a lot of Open Source
coding I also sometimes do book stuff
and other sort of just random uh things
that I need to do and I do this as a
method of keeping me from checking
Facebook every five minutes it's pretty
great and I highly recommend live
streaming to anyone with executive
function challenges
um I'm a co-author of a lot of books my
publisher would be very upset if I did
not encourage you to buy them if you
have a corporate credit card it is the
gift of April
um everyone loves receiving books uh
especially if you have a corporate
credit card now if you don't have a
corporate credit card don't don't waste
your time but corporate credit cards are
fantastic and I wish I still had one
the other one is well I am here to talk
about teaching children distributed
systems specifically we're going to
focus a little bit on spark uh you know
and my employer does use spark we don't
currently teach children how to program
spark right so these are my own views of
ways of how we could teach kids to
program spark
of course they some of them think it's
entertaining I'm sure some of them don't
anyways in addition to who I am
professionally right I'm trans I'm queer
a I'm Canadian I I got a green card I'm
super excited about that is slightly
harder to kick me out of this place
um and I'm a part of the broader leather
community and now this this oh thank you
the one person oh okay thank you many
people um anyways this doesn't have a
lot of bearing uh there is no secret
Canadian decoder ring that makes spark
exceptions make sense uh if there was I
would make more money
um but I think it's important for those
of us who are building tools uh
specifically data tools and machine
learning tools to talk about where we're
from and also realize when we're in a
room and we find out that everyone went
to say UC Berkeley
um maybe it's time to get some more
people in that room uh who didn't go to
UC Berkeley no no offense to people who
went to UC Berkeley I just I've been in
a lot of rooms where I was the one
person who didn't go to UC Berkeley
um Okay cool so
um what what is this about so I think
um Richard Feynman said this this
amazingly it's important for us to be
able to explain things simply and I
think that we can actually do this with
distributed computing I think that we
should try and teach children
distributed computing not because we
hate children and we want them to get
out of memory exceptions that is a
benefit of course
um but because I think in doing so we
will be able to clarify our own
understanding and by explaining things
simply
um we can actually ensure that we know
what's going on I find sometimes when I
have to explain things to people I
realize I don't I don't actually know
what I'm talking about and then I have
to go back and and figure it out because
like my understanding is sort of fuzzy
and in the process of writing it down or
then the process of talking about it
with someone that's when it's really
becomes clear also this is my dog he's
amazing I love him and I miss him okay
um
so why why distributed computing for
kids and why spark as the starting point
so spark tricked a lot of adults into
thinking about data parallelism and
incidentally along the way we were able
to teach a lot of adults about
functional programming
um and now this this might not be
something that you're particularly
excited about but I love functional
programming so if I can trick adults
maybe I can trick children also into
learning functional programming and then
there will be more people that I can
hang out with and we can you know write
maps and filters and and do all of the
cool liquid at all of the cool kid
things
um and so maybe we can use spark as a
method of introducing children to the
idea of functional programming and
importantly I I think
in many ways functional programming is
actually easier to learn as a first
language right if you if you have this
mutation you have like all of the state
that you have to kind of keep in your
head and understand but with systems
like spark when they work and to be
clear that is not all the time
bordering on rarely you don't have to
think about all of this state right and
I think this is really cool okay
so uh we're going to go ahead and we're
going to open our PDF
and this is this is our super fun PDF uh
distributed computing for kids
um
and this this
exists and you can see that it is
clearly made by some queer people
um you know
these are these are children and gnomes
and this is perhaps not what
mainstream Society might think children
and garden gnomes look like but if you
leave it to some people from San
Francisco and Berlin this is what you
get
uh um okay
so initially when I when I came up with
the idea of teaching children uh Apache
spark I was like maybe I should drink
less
um and that was definitely true the
other part of it was okay maybe there
are some parts that we can explain to a
lot of people and there are some parts
that we can explain to them when they're
a little bit older and they've seen some
python code before right and I think
this is this is one of the things that I
want to sort of say is we can teach
people the concepts before we
necessarily have to teach them the
syntax right and I think the concepts of
distributed systems are actually really
simple and it's the the syntax and the
programming that kind of gets in our way
um but that being said you know the
concepts aren't particularly useful
without the tools So eventually we do
have to we do have to teach them the
concrete way of doing things
um and so
the theory here
um is that we'll we'll teach children
distributed systems and then eventually
we'll teach them uh the terribleness
that is distributed systems in the real
world
um
and so in theory right we're going to
start off with trying to explain to them
why you would want to do this at all
right because like
I don't know about you but when I was a
kid and people tried to teach me things
a pretty common refraine that I heard
was like are we ever going to use this
like what is this for right and it's
like no like we actually use distributed
systems for a whole bunch of really cool
things in our world right search engines
might not be as cool as they once were
um but you know we use it for
recommendation algorithms and those are
certainly really cool right uh
you can tell I'm pretty out of touch
because I think recommendation
algorithms are going to be hip and with
it for the kids
um but I'm doing my best here I'm doing
my best here okay
um and similarly I think it's important
that we we draw parallels to things that
that people already understand right
using multiple computers and using
working with multiple people is pretty
similar and I think most of us are used
to the idea of like hey is this a
problem which is going to be easier to
do by myself or is this a problem where
if I get my friends help this is
actually going to go faster right and I
think that's that's a good framework to
have
um and we can think about like similarly
the the explaining of what to do is very
similar to our serializing our code and
sending it over the wire and if we have
to serialize huge chunks of data and
send it over the wire it's not going to
be it's not going to be good okay
ah
so right we we sort of introduced the
concept of like what is distributed
computing it's when we use multiple
computers to solve a problem right and
the other important part is explaining
that unfortunately computers do not
understand our language although that
might be changing a little bit
um inconvenient uh book is already out
of date before it's finished in the
grand tradition uh but I wouldn't want
it any other way
um and so this this very much goes like
hey what's up here's some nice pictures
uh and we're going to start with a
concrete example and that's sort of how
we're going to explain everything
because when we think about things in a
concrete way and then generalize it I
find it it is easier than going the
other way around
um and once again to show how out of
touch I am with actual children
um we use Instagram as our example with
the theory that Instagram is kind of
cool I probably should have picked Tick
Tock uh I don't know
um
we we could probably replace Instagram
with Tick Tock neither of these are
actually probably legal for children to
be using
um in America but as far as I can tell
that has stopped precisely three
children from using tiktok or Instagram
uh they don't care they don't care uh
okay and so then also we can see
important uh disclaimer my my amazing
friend who's who's working on the
illustrations there are going to be a
bunch of missing illustrations here and
you'll have to use your imagination to
fill them in
um and that's for a variety of reasons
um
yeah none of which I want to Super go
into but if anyone's curious we can we
can talk about why the illustrations are
taking a bit longer but it turns out
that humans are terrible at estimating
timelines for drawings and writing
software oh yeah okay
so we start out and our main characters
are Alex and Ziva and we we talk about
how what they want to do is they want to
take photos for Instagram and really
probably should have been recording
videos for Tick Tock but they want to
pick something that's popular right
because everyone feel I shouldn't say
everyone most people feel that Joy when
you know we get interaction on social
media that's how
these things keep us engaged despite
being arguably terrible for us
um and so one of the things that we want
to do is figure out what are the things
that are popular but not just what are
the things that are popular in general
what are the things that are popular
with my friends
um
and so in in practice you know you you
could probably just look and count it up
by hand uh for just your friends if you
wanted to see what your friends were
talking about but in our in our
hypothetical World Alex and Ziva have
some super popular friends and so
figuring this out is really hard right
and they're also much like me incredibly
lazy they don't want to go through all
the posts on Instagram they're going to
trick our friendly garden gnomes into
helping us out
um and we're going to do it by trading
them some tea
um probably should have said coffee but
you know tea is tea is good teeth feels
more know me to me I don't know why I
just felt like it felt uh fit with the
theme a bit better and so yes picture
them hanging out in the backyard
um and they've got their mobile phones
and we've got some garden gnomes who are
foraging around for tea everyone has
that picture in their head
no okay well whatever um
say I love you so our garden gnome
friends offer to help right Alex and
Ziva they've they've been looking up
their phones they've been writing down
you know what they think the popular
tags are but they're they're getting
kind of frustrated and the garden gnomes
stand-up folk stand up folk and so the
garden gnomes start downloading
Instagram
and this is because normally they use
gnomestagram which is much more Toad's
dual Focus than Instagram so they have
to download a new app this is equivalent
to pip installing our dependencies on
all of the workers at the start is
downloading Instagram onto our phone or
conda install sorry didn't mean to
uh however you want to do it and the
other part here that we introduce is
this pile of index cards and this is an
idea that like hey you know each of the
gnomes are going to be having work that
they're going to be doing on their own
but we're also going to probably be
doing something
with sharing these like it's not just
writing down one big list we're probably
using these index cards for a reason
which we'll get to later okay so picture
a bunch of ins index cards a bunch of
gnomes somehow on cell phones installing
Instagram and there we go very good okay
now we've got one of our gnomes Brewing
some tea
and we elect a leader now in in practice
in Apache spark we don't actually do
leader elections if you've looked at the
log messages you do see that it says
things like elect leader but it's very
much electing a leader like
[Music]
um
well I would say how my dog elects the
leader which is obviously my dog uh 100
of the time the leader election is the
same person uh so very fair 100 percent
legitimate election no questions okay
so our leader gnome is going to be
responsible for sort of dividing up uh
these the stack of index cards so that
each gnome is getting a fair share a
fair amount of the work right and so
these index cards have the names of
different friends of Alex and Ziva and
we want to make sure that like none of
the gnomes are going to take way way
longer right how many people here have
had spark or dask or array have the
situation where one of your workers is
taking much longer than the other
okay and how many of you have never had
that and do use one of those tools
yeah okay that's what I thought great so
um 100 actual real thing legitimate
discussion okay cool
um and we talk about how you know this
would impact the workflow negatively
namely The Gnome that got done first
would go and drink some tea and get kind
of bored and then none of the other
gnomes would be able to have any tea and
this would of course be a great travesty
uh the real world version of this is you
will light a bunch of your money on fire
and give it to insert dollar sign cloud
provider here
uh okay
so
we've decided that our leader is not
going to be responsible for doing any of
the actual work just like uh in many
corporations
um the leader is going to be responsible
for doing the managing which is which is
work too which is work too and actually
in in real spark the leader might have
an Executor scheduled on them and they
might and indeed actually do some work
so this is we we toy with the metaphor a
little bit here
um but then we start to talk about like
how the gnomes are going to record the
data that they're finding right and so
they record best dog and coffee because
those are the those are the tags that
they've seen so far
um and we talk about how each gnome is
responsible for their own stack of cards
right and this is this is really
important we don't have like one big
shared list because if we had one big
shared list you know obviously there
will be contention gnome fights would
break out not good not good in reality
like in the real world uh our Network
would be slow everyone would be sad but
in our in our hypothetical World we're
all concerned about the book and the T
and we don't we don't want any gnome
fights okay
so we finally get to our gnomes on the
toadstools and they're going to go ahead
and they're going to figure out what
these counts are right and we we talk
about making tally marks
um and we also have one of them drinking
tea we can see how the leader has
decided that of course you know they're
just going to take a little break and
drink some tea
um just like in real life
um sorry sorry I hope my bosses doesn't
watch this
um if you do it's not you not you
anyways
um okay
so we talk about how they're using the
index cards because they know later on
their goal is going to be to combine
these counts and they want something
that well they could each have their own
pad of paper by using a separate index
card for each word it's going to make
this combining easier later on
we see some samples super lovely I don't
know if I should take the drunk gnome
out or leave it in
um I kind of want to leave it in and see
if I can get it published I'm thinking I
might have to replace uh the bottle of
liquor uh with some tea
um but here you know we've got the text
that the gnome got tired instead of The
Gnome is hung over
um right and we can think about like
yeah the The Gnome is just a little
tired you know he had a little bit too
much to drink last night the tea was
just too delicious
uh that dandelion tea it gets you gets
you every time
um but similarly this is talking about
how the implications similar to when you
try and coordinate a group project with
five people one of them just isn't going
to do their
um and if you try and do a distributed
systems project with 100 computers at
least one of them is gonna like crash
right like that's that's life uh
computers are terrible but so are people
yay okay
um
um right okay
um and the leader of course picks
another gnome to take over for the gnome
who had a little bit too much sauce
mm-hmm okay
uh and now once again we're back to the
place where you have to use your
imagination my sincerest apologies I
assure you it's temporary
um so we're getting to the point where
it's time to combine our work right and
so this is Spark's amazing Shuffle also
known as really really slow
um and so here we're talking about how
the leader is coming up with with the
shuffle mechanism
um and this explanation needs
I would say it needs some more love and
we need probably a little bit of a
better diagram than this
trying not triangle whatever thing we
need a real diagram here
um but the idea is that similar to spark
we're going to do sort of range based
partitioning
um I figured we could skip the hash
partitioner and just go with the range
based partitioner even though the
default is definitely going to be the
hash based partitioner the range
partitioner is a lot easier to
understand so we talk about the Gnomes
and how they're going to get together
and they're going to trade their cards
and then they're going to combine them
fun all kinds of fun okay and now each
of our gnomes has you know different
cards there they've combined them and
they've got their tags and their
accounts and they're going to find the
one with the highest count so in theory
we're doing essentially an implicit sort
by with a take one
um from the from the highest and in
practice Sparks Optimizer may or may not
end up executing it in this way but it
is it is a valid way where it could end
up executing it where instead of
actually doing a shuffle uh it simply
asks each node for its highest count
and so it turns out that our highest
count value is Puffin life and this is
because I think puffins are kind of cool
and I forgot to put a puffin in at the
start of the story
um so now we've got a puffin
yay okay and we balance the puff end on
a toadstool and we take some pictures
wearing silly hats all kinds of fun
their friends find it's amazing
computers have saved the day I mean
gnomes gnomes have saved the day no
Shooters here
okay
so now we're setting ourselves up for
the second book where we start talking
about
the real world which is of course
terrible and so we talk about how
um
what they've done with the Gnomes is
indeed very similar to what we could do
with Apache spark and then this is this
is where we run out in prints and
credits and stuff uh there is more text
but no more images and once again this
is because estimating images is about as
accurate as sorry estimating creative
work is about as accurate as estimating
uh programming work which is to say not
very much
okay
so yes
um this is as far as we got with the
illustrations and the formatting but all
of the text is here this very convenient
link which I am now realizing I probably
should have put a link shortener on and
I will definitely do that afterwards and
tweet it and put it on blue sky or
Mastodon or whatever I don't know how
many of them there are anymore but I
will definitely share this with you in a
way where you do not have to take a
picture uh unless you really really like
typing a lot in which case go for it
live your best life
um
and we can see here yeah
yeah
um there used to be an earlier version
of this where the Gnomes were literally
terrifying which taught me that five
dollars is not enough money to spend on
illustrations
um
but we can see we actually do have a
part two of the book
um it is it is not yet
turned into nice illustrations
um but you know we've got importing the
library we've got pip install we've got
all sort of the same things that we've
just done before but redone with python
so that we can use computers instead of
garden gnomes because it turns out that
most people don't have magical garden
gnomes available to do their bidding if
you do please come and find me I want
some garden gnomes and so yeah we
replace all the instructions with python
I like fart jokes so we also put in a
bunch of fart jokes
um I'm told children like fart jokes too
and that is great
um yeah and then so it turns out the
like gnome part was the relatively easy
part and the python part is the
relatively sad part
um but that's okay right like I think if
you've got the concept learning the
syntax afterwards is going to be kind of
frustrating but it's easier than trying
to do both at the same time and I think
if we can explain the concepts to people
then we probably understand the concepts
and that's kind of cool okay uh let's
make sure I go back to the right slides
yes great
okay to the Future
um I don't remember why I chose Cheeto
Mac cheese extra spicy
um I do have to say this is disgusting
do not eat it
um
but I did buy a case of it on Amazon so
I am slowly working my way through it if
you're in San Francisco and want some
cheesy jalapeno Cheeto Mac cheese come
and find me
uh and once again my dog is amazing okay
so
this is great and all right data
parallelism is cool we all we all are
many of us probably love data
parallelism but
can't solve all of our problems with
data parallelism right
um clearly the solution to this is to
teach children about task parallelism
and actors because what could go wrong
okay
um so I I was thinking about this and we
can do the same thing with garden gnomes
although
as as we've seen the illustrations for
the data parallelism part are not
finished so we're not we're we're not
going to have the garden gnomes
available for task parallelism just yet
um but my thought here is that we can do
task parallelism with garden gnomes and
we can use dask to to show this to
people it's hard to show task
parallelism and Spark because that's all
behind private apis and I think
that teaching children to call Java from
python is a step too far
um you know we we all have our limits
right
okay
um but anyways we'll focus on how each
gnome can do different work
um focus on side effects and and sort of
other things there similarly we can
teach them actors this is also of course
just an excuse to show you more pictures
of my dog
um so we can we can do stuff with actors
and my my idea here is we could either
take the same example and talk about how
the leader got tired and lazy and didn't
really want to keep track of all of the
accounts and we wanted more than just
the top one so we were going to make
each person responsible for this range
and we're going to store and update
things and we're going to do streaming
because children love streaming data
sources
right right okay one person agrees I
love it love it the alternative was we
could do model weights
um but I thought that teaching children
logistic regression was once again like
a bridge too far so like let's stick
with word count because everyone loves
word count right everyone loves word
count
okay uh and now a word from my employer
um so uh most glorious employer who can
oh wait this is being recorded
um we are hiring if you would like to
exchange labor for money my employer is
very interested in more people working
in the data platform organization uh
unfortunately I don't think this is my
specific team but we have a lot of
really wonderful sister teams that are
hiring and it's mostly at the like
college grad or like new
to the industry sort of level
um since it's not my team directly I
don't know the manager
um but please please do apply and they
would love that if you're super senior
I'm sure you can apply to but like I
don't think we have open head count for
that right now although if you're
watching a recording of This maybe by
the time
you watch it uh they are trying to hire
my replacement no just kidding just
kidding no one would ever want to do
that
hmm okay but more importantly what you
should do is you should go and give me
your email address to contact in a
definitely not spammy way
for updates to distributed computing for
kids so that you too can share the joy
of out of memory exceptions and screen
flickering to all of the children in
your life
um or you know the children on your
block provided that uh you know their
parents agree because I I think we can
all agree out of memory exceptions do
require Parental Guidance and permission
um okay
so
I was hoping and and this may be a
optimistic hope but I was hoping that
there might be questions or ideas for
things that we could teach children
about
um and distributed computing and other
things that we can add I see one hand in
the back is there a microphone for the
person with the hand in the back yes
okay
um someone is coming to you with a
microphone in the meantime uh
hmm let's see here
uh what messages would glorious employer
like to pass on
I can't think of any more besides we're
hiring oh hello hi my name is Julie I'm
actually a teacher I teach grades 5th
through 10th
math and geometry in algebra
I also teach robotics
that's hella cool thanks thanks
um and I was just wondering
um if you're gonna make some lesson
plans perhaps that we could like you
know use in the classroom that's like
really smart yo
I love it I love it uh So the plan was
to like finish the illustrations so that
it doesn't have quite as much like
random
I don't even remember the name of the
shape you're a geometry teacher what yes
yes I am a geometry teacher okay less
rhombuses apparently okay whatever
um diamonds whatever yeah um so yes uh
eventually would you like to contribute
lesson plans together sure yeah yay
that's good yeah
um so yeah uh there's it's in a very
organized mixture of Google docs uh and
uh GitHub repo
um and and we can collaborate
electronically but we can also hang out
and and press the buttons
sounds cool where do you live I live in
San Francisco oh okay we might have to
hang out electronically yeah okay gotcha
um but yeah yeah I think I think making
lesson plans would be really cool I
wanted to to finish the illustrations
but we could start on the lesson plans
now too yeah all right cool let's talk
yay
are there any other questions
oh yay
good question thank you so um I think I
like the comparison between the data
parallelism and attack styleism so one
thing that I see is like the framework
that is very much tax parallelism
focused like Ryan Dax they also extend
to
processing distributed data so what do
you think about is that a problem like
why why why don't they just focus on
like pure like tax distribution for
distributed computing why do they extend
to data as well is there any an issue
with that any limitation with that you
see
could you repeat that sure yeah so my
hearing is a little bad I'm sorry so um
yeah my observation is like the
framework that it was built on
tax parallelism parallelism like Dax and
Rey right so I saw them also extend to
uh possessing distribute data big data
right so um do you think that is a
it's a wrong move like
can that be as efficient as the
framework that focuses on for the
beginning on data parallelism like Spark
cool so not directly related to to this
but more sort of in general yes
is that yeah so okay cool so my question
is like is that a problem that they
so I mean I think so if you see any
problem with that I'm gonna I'm Gonna
State what I think your question is and
you can you can tell me if I got it
right so I think your question is like
uh
there's tools like spark in the Big Data
space And Then There are newer python
tools like dask and Ray
and
um they they're both starting from
different places and do the tools like
desk and Ray are is there adding of big
data support
uh like equivalent or problematic in
some way yeah yeah cool okay yeah so
um and I want to be clear right like
this is in some ways like going to a
Toyota dealer and asking like hey those
GM cars are they any good
um right because like I I fundamentally
like I work on spark for my day job
right now on on the on the flip side I
of course use Rey and I use dasc and I'm
writing books or written books about
those topics as well so it's not
entirely by us but I do
I do want to sort of disclaim that my
interpretation
might be a little uh skewed towards
spark
um
so I think if we think back to to Apache
spark and how it developed right it
started with uh batch data parallelism
and then tried to adopt some of the
ideas from Apache Flink which is the
streaming service and initially it went
about as well as one might expect but
over time it got a lot better and I
think in some ways uh Ray and dask right
um
did not start with the same data
parallel Focus but you can do data
parallel operations on them and they
will continue to improve I think they're
focused at slightly different use cases
I think for example
uh dask has a much better distributed
pandas Library than spark does right
that's that's just if you want
distributed pandas you probably want to
ask
um on the other hand if you want to like
integrate with like
a whole bunch of Legacy Hadoop systems
that's probably going to be kind of
painful to do in dasc um and you you
might be better served uh in spark
um
and now things get a bit more
complicated with Rey which
is
starting with more of a focus on machine
learning
and I would say
that's an awkward place for me to talk
about because I need to work with both
of them and they're both great
Yeehaw
um but no like uh I would say Rey is
more focused towards machine learning
tasks than pure data tasks and if you
don't need to do machine learning and
you're like just doing a whole bunch of
data stuff
you might be better served by
desk or spark but if you need to do like
a bunch of fancy machine learning stuff
you might be better served by Ray
and I think that is enough that no one
in any of those communities will no
longer talk to me
um my sincerest apologies to anyone who
I offended
thank you
cool I think we have another question
over there oh and one here oh yeah
wait sorry could you oh I see
um
could you raise your hand yeah yeah
so I think it's really great how
you've kind of taken this mental model
and applied it to a children's book
setting I'm curious if you have any
thoughts kind of on the Fly because this
is not distributed computing so much but
um like I feel like you could read this
book and a kid would get the concept of
distributed computing I think something
that humans struggle with is taking
these Concepts and bringing them to
scale right so like okay what if it's
not just like all the Gnomes in my
backyard but what if it's like all the
Gnomes on planet Earth and there's
Millions there's hundreds of millions of
them right
um as we all know
um and then all the all the Gnomes in
the solar system then we're talking
about billions of gnomes and those are
things that you know I have I have
problems comprehending and I think as
you know
as human beings we continue to deal with
larger larger scale problems we have to
figure out how to communicate to younger
and younger people what it what it means
to be one versus 10 versus 100 to
million billion trillion
yeah I so that's a great question
um so I think in in some ways like for
example
one of the things that we could think
about is uh like a natural follow-on
question is like okay let's say that
they wanted to do this for all of the
Instagram posts right like what is going
to no longer work right well
um as much as we perhaps made light of
uh the manager gnomes tasks the manager
gnome is probably going to be the one
who's going to struggle there right and
so it's like okay so how do we split up
this management and coordination task
and how do we make it so that it's not
just one person trying to manage uh
every gnome in planet Earth right and
trust me I've seen gnomes fight you do
not want one gnome trying to manage all
the Gnomes like that is not going to
work out right you there's no factions
it's not good it's not good
um
but I
I don't know about arbitrary scale right
I think
um I think like a really good question
that we could ask is is similar where
it's just like okay
where do we think it's going to break
next right and that's
um
I think that's something that comes from
experience unfortunately uh but we can
try and encode that experience in in
examples
uh like like this
um
cool
uh I think there's yeah
do you have a microphone yet or no yeah
I have a microphone yeah I have a
potential analogy suggestion
um you might consider making the analogy
of spark and Santa
because like how does Santa do it like
as he adds more elves he's able to build
more presents and there might be a good
way to motivate it and connect with kids
there I like it I like it Santa is very
popular much much more popular yeah no
okay yeah I
great suggestion sure
thank you it's a great talk
um
I personally I've never had the
opportunity to explain discrepancy
Computing skits presumably because they
understand spark much better than me
um unfortunately I have had bosses and
stakeholders ask me questions about
spark and distributed computing and
building complex software systems that
are often light
um are there any principles you think
that could be applied to that mob
business focused use case or the
principles that should be invited
so I think I think that's that's also
um there is of course always some I
shouldn't say there is often sudden
subtext of
computer books that are ostensibly for
kids is that it's also
for people who maybe don't have the same
background that everyone else does right
like we don't make the same assumptions
here on the flip side right if you you
know talk to your manager about garden
gnomes getting drunk in the backyard
this might be an exciting opportunity to
update your resume
um
and trust me I've had a few of those uh
so you know I I think there's there's
some limitations to sort of how we can
how we can carry that over
um
I find that when I'm trying to explain
things to management it's often a matter
of trade-offs
um and less a matter of trying to
explain
the intricacies of how something is
actually functioning
sometimes they they do want to know the
intricacies of how something functions
in that case drunken garden gnomes might
be our fastest way to success but I
think a lot of times
what what I see from stakeholders is
if provided the trust is there it's very
much like what are our options and how
do we how do we choose right like
um the the question earlier with you
know dasc and Spark and Rey and it's
like well
you know this is roughly how I would
sort them and then we can talk about of
course the trade-offs right we can talk
about how Apache Sparks dependency
management system is effectively YOLO
um and
raise dependency management system is
not just YOLO and how that has some
implications when it comes to trying to
iterate quickly with machine learning
but of course you know it might be more
challenging for us to get our data
and
so that's that's normally how I like to
have my like stakeholder conversations
um but if they don't trust me then uh
uh that's really hard in that case I
normally try and figure out a small
problem that they're facing today with a
tool that they're already using and fix
that for them as a as a starting point
for like hey like we're actually on the
same side here and then if you do that a
few times then they they might start to
trust your analysis
uh but uh
you know if you want to show them garden
gnomes good luck
I think we have time for one more
question
if there are any if we're done okay I
guess we're done yet let's uh think
Holden for joining us today
foreign